good morning we are in the middle of a
deposition involving Ambassador Hale who
is the third more senior official at the
State Department and the top career
official at the State Department so I'm
going to have to keep this brief but
first of all I want to thank ambassador
Hale for for being here for obeying the
law for following the lawful subpoena
that we issued we wish others would show
the same courage and dedication to the
law that ambassador Hale is
demonstrating here today I want to let
you know as you may know already that we
will begin our open hearings in the
impeachment inquiry next week we will be
beginning with the testimony of
ambassador Taylor and a bastard Kent on
Wednesday and we will have ambassador
Jovanovic testify on Friday these will
be the first of the open hearings and I
think you will see throughout the course
of the testimony not only their
testimony others the most important
facts are largely not contested we are
getting an increasing appreciation for
just what took place during the course
of the last year and the degree to which
the president enlisted whole departments
of government in the illicit aim of
trying to get Ukraine to dig up dirt on
a political opponent as well as further
conspiracy theory about the 2016
election that he believed would be
beneficial to his re-election campaign
so those open hearings will be an
opportunity for the American people to
evaluate the witnesses for themselves to
make their own determinations about the
credibility of the witnesses but also to
learn firsthand about the facts of the
president's misconduct along those lines
today we will be releasing the
deposition transcript of ambassador
Taylor so people will have the
opportunity to read about that that
position as well and what Americans will
see from that transcript is what they
have seen from the others that the GOP
claims to be locked out prohibited from
participating unable to ask questions
are simply false
in Ambassador Taylor's deposition has
indeed in every deposition the
Republican members have had equal
opportunity with Democratic members to
ask any questions they would like I
think you will see in the transcript
what a dedicated public servant
ambassador Taylor is someone who
graduated from West Point someone who
served in Vietnam someone who is I think
performing another vital service for the
country in relating the facts that came
to his attention the very disturbing
facts that came to his attention so we
move forward with the open phase of the
impeachment inquiry we still have some
remaining depositions to do which will
be conducting over the next couple days
and with that we were gonna head back